la crisis en las islas francesas de
ultramar se agudiza la ira por las
medidas impuestas para controlar el cob
y 19 por las que ahora es obligatoria la
vacunación para los trabajadores de la
salud avivaron un problema social
latente las tasas de vacunación en los
territorios son inferiores a las del
continente los habitantes de las islas
de guadalupe y martinica se han sentido
marginados durante mucho tiempo por el
gobierno central en este evento la la
ayuda desconfianza fuerte pero que no es
nueva vimos muchas manifestación muchas
huelgas esos últimos años entonces esto
está enmarcado justamente en un fenómeno
que se está ya llevando desde hace años
la desconfianza de las élites francesas
del poder central giacominismo además
viven en una realidad económica muy
diferente en la que se vive en francia
continental es un problema de desempleo
un problema de costo de vida que es más
o menos 12% más caro que en francia el
nivel de pobreza es dos veces superior
es decir que hay una desigualdad total
que se puede justamente sentir y no hay
lucha real en el tema de conocer la
precariedad que conoce justamente el
país las protestas marcan una prueba
para el gobierno del presidente manuel
macro no hay olvidar que esta isla ha
votado por mayoría forma cron en la la
las anteriores elecciones entonces se
pensaban justamente tener más apoyo del
gobierno central y en este momento no le
están teniendo los disturbios se
producen en un momento difícil para
francia a menos de cinco meses de las
elecciones presidenciales